now
what to do with you
hey guys pete here this week there was a
lot of news and teaser stuff that came
out for the back half of better call
saul's final season taken individually
there's not much to say about any one
thing so today i thought i would do a
video that covers all of them in one
place i'm going with a different format
here because i was talking with the
vivid kiwi who is a frequent guest on
our live streams and as we were getting
into what we think all of this stuff
means it seemed like we could turn this
conversation into a video so kiwi is
here and we'll be speculating if you're
not caught up through season 6 episode 7
or you're just averse to speculation
then this video will have spoilers but
just to be clear
neither one of us has seen episode 8 or
have had it spoiled for us yet and with
that out of the way let's get into it
alright so episode 608 was screened for
a large audience in new york city at the
tribeca film festival last weekend
we weren't lucky enough to attend but we
did have a couple of friends of the
channel who were there to see it early
and they report that it was a solid
episode that keeps up with the intensity
and pace of episode 7. i haven't really
heard anyone say too much that was
negative about this the reaction i've
seen has been universally positive we'll
say and there was also a panel
discussion that had a lot of people
talking about it because it was peter
gould gordon smith bob odenkirk tony
dalton and ray seahorn all there to
answer questions
and you know this is a crazy lineup i
can't imagine how much fun this would
have been to watch a new episode with
this many people in general but then on
top of that have jimmy kim lalo and
everyone else there in attendance i mean
what do you think about that
yeah the tribeca screening sounded like
a lot of fun i wish i knew about it in
advance i would have seriously
considered going i didn't actually hear
anything about it until like the day
before it happened but uh on better
castle's instagram i believe but yeah
that sounds like a lot of fun not only
to watch better call saul on the big
screen but to also you know be in the
same room as all of these amazing people
i would have definitely just enjoyed the
panel as a fan in general as i've always
wanted to go to like san diego comic con
and see a panel by them or something
like that so it would have been just a
huge bucket list moment hopefully
there's something like that in the
future something else where you know we
can see them on a panel i'm not too sure
how many more panels they'll be doing or
anything like that uh yeah we're kind of
running out of time huh yeah considering
the show's wrapping up so i'm not too
sure how many more opportunities there
are for that but yeah it sounds like a
lot of fun for sure
yeah and it sounds like there were also
some interesting tidbits that came out
in that discussion
i saw one uh poster on reddit who copied
down some of the things i guess they
asked everyone you know to sum up the
final six episodes in just a short
statement and um after a very long pause
ray seahorn said that it's provocative
and psychologically disturbing
peter gould said
multi-chromatic
which you know that's interesting
because obviously the gene scenes are
monochromatic they're black and white
and
this hints that that will be involved or
you know it sounds pretty heavily
involved in those last couple episodes
and bob said it was going to be a second
life
and then the posts are put in
parentheses but you don't know what that
even means so i don't know if bob said
that or if that is added um
if that's just inferred
yeah
so you know i thought that was pretty
cool did you hear anything
worth mentioning from people who had
been there have you have you seen
anything that popped out
uh not necessarily i had a few people
message me saying that they were there
but they were very polite and didn't
spoil anything thankfully
i did briefly skim through uh gill's uh
non-spoiler uh podcast uh
and
i'm just really curious about this
multi-chromatic thing because i'm
wondering if he's talking about the
better call salt timeline or if he's
talking about the gene timeline like you
said because
uh just to elaborate on that a bit it's
been just a huge theory ever since way
back in season one you know is gene
gonna have color come back into his life
what is that going to symbolize exactly
and with gene possibly reverting back to
saul and all that sort of thing or maybe
gene going to prison i did a video on
that recently or even maybe a gene and
kim reunion there's just so many options
as to the routes that they could take
this i don't know i guess i'm just glad
that they didn't
they said things that made us really
start thinking about it but not enough
to truly spoil anything so i think they
tread the line there pretty well yeah
they're pretty good at it and um i did
also listen to gil uh gail from one take
who's a
you know a big contributor to the live
streams on on that we do after the
episodes here
and the big thing that stood out for me
there was that apparently they asked ray
seahorn about how much kim has been
influenced by jimmy and how much was
what we've seen as her darker side you
know was that already there
and ray said that she personally really
enjoys the conversation that happens
around the question and likes that it's
open to interpretation you know she
didn't really want to answer but instead
kept to things like how kim is complex
she's a complicated character and how
interesting that makes her then i guess
bob swooped in and asked if he could
answer that
and said that you know it was already
there she has a darker side and part of
why she seems so reserved in the
beginning is because she's trying to
hide that or she has something to hide i
think is the way that they put it but um
i i you know that's the thing out of
what they were saying that kind of stood
out to me
yeah i think it's interesting how
uh ray doesn't really want to give a
straight up answer but then bob does i
i've read stuff that bob's indicated
that before in interviews even before
the season came out so i guess that's
his line you know that that he he sticks
to i'd say pretty consistently ray's
been the other way you know i don't
think they really said anything new here
but it is it is interesting like he said
that he followed after her and basically
answered the question that she didn't
want to well the thing is with the uh
with the character flashbacks for this
show uh the creators try to tread the
line as to
imply why a character may act the way
they do but they don't want to dumb it
down to just this one specific moment
pretty much summarizes the whole
character and their motivations all at
once the reason why bob probably sweep
didn't answer it is because we got that
kim flashback in season six implying
that maybe kim did have a dark side to
her as a kid or as a teenager who knows
maybe she could have conned with her mom
or at least uh having her mom as a con
man in her life from a young age
definitely influenced that dark side of
her and i think that's a part of why
when she started to grow up she realized
that her life wasn't going anywhere and
then that's why she moved to mexico to
go on the straight and narrow and become
a workaholic lawyer another example of
the creators not really wanting to just
dumb down a character to one specific
moment was during one of the chuck
flashbacks uh when he was having dinner
with rebecca and jimmy um
when i think it was when chuck says a
joke that falls flat to rebecca due to
being jealous that jimmy was really
talking her up and having a good time
apparently originally after that moment
uh chuck was gonna reach over and touch
a touch a lamp and have it shock him
implying that that's the moment that his
uh sort of allergy to electricity
started but i guess they cut that
because they didn't want it to be that
specific instead just left it a bit more
ambiguous so i feel like that's kind of
why ray didn't want to answer they
didn't want it to be too specific but
then again we have gotten the kim
flashback so that's probably why bob
swooped in and confirmed that yeah that
dark side to her was already there and
that uh
jimmy is just sort of reawakening that
yeah i mean i think we we've discussed
it several times in the streams and i
know i do in my videos about people
don't change like that they don't change
in an instant it happens slowly over
time and and that's why this you know
these characters resonate so much is
because they are complicated and they
are like real people
and you know speaking of characters one
of the biggest bits and news that came
out of this was that bob odenkirk teased
that there will be a character that's
completely new to this universe and
they're going to be introducing this
person in the last six episodes he said
it is a actor that will blow our minds
you know a great great actor and in his
words a classic of all time which that
sounds pretty impressive except for it's
an actor talking about another actor so
you know it's pretty hard to speculate
on there's a there's a lot of different
people that could fit into that category
but i mean it also seems a little late
in the game to introduce someone who'll
be key to the story that's never been in
either show before so like what was your
initial take on this
yeah so
to be honest i i wasn't entirely sure
initially i guess with the whole howard
and nacho situations being out of the
way and you know chuck not being in the
show for a while there's room for new
characters which is kind of why they
brought wallow in to replace truck as
being the main antagonist
it seems interesting that bob implied
it's played by a famous actor now i've
always been interested on what they do
after uh sort of the wallow howard plot
concludes with episodes to spare so
maybe this new character has to do with
that and as i was telling you uh behind
the scenes i almost don't want the show
to end and i wish there was time for
another arc afterwards uh as as amazing
as the howard and lalo's situation is i
i've always just had in the back of my
mind but what happens after is that
gonna take up the whole season are we
going to have time for another arc is it
just going to be kind of conclusion for
all where all the characters end up
going into breaking bad
so it really just depends on how many
episodes are left in the better castle
timeline versus the breaking bad or gene
timelines which again has been a popular
topic of discussion especially in the
live streams bob acted like the new
character would play a major role in
most of the final six episodes he could
just be uh you know trying not to spoil
as to when the character actually does
show up because for all we know it could
just be in a single episode like a jean
episode or this character could just
suddenly you know take up a main role
for the following episodes of the better
call saul timeline
yeah when we initially talked about this
i i
interpreted what he said as it almost
had to be a cameo you know like just an
appearance you know somebody who was was
recognizable and you know that hadn't
shown up before so yeah i was thinking
you know leaning more towards he might
show up in a cold open or or they i
should say i don't we don't know what
the gender will be if it's going to be a
guy or or a woman in this but i mean
it's really hard to figure out where
there's a lot of extra story that needs
new characters where you know like my
thinking has sort of been that
this lalo situation that they're there
and we'll talk about this a little bit
more when we talk about the the teaser
but you know i figure there's maybe one
or two episodes there i kind of think
probably two for their that plan to play
out and then maybe some you know an
episode of the aftermath or something
like that and then i'm expecting that
they're gonna move into breaking bad and
gene territory some based on what
they're what they've said you know that
they isn't just wishful thinking on my
part i i feel like that you know they've
kind of laid that out that that those
things are going to happen
so i i didn't think that he was saying
that this was going to be somebody that
would be you know dominant in what
happens in the last six episodes but you
kind of thought it was the other way
around that this was going to be someone
who we were going to see a lot of
yeah but again i i kind of do goof what
you're saying in regards to how much
time do we truly have for another
character to show up it's kind of the
same discussion as talking about more
breaking bad cameos coming into play
because although it would be nice to see
all these other characters from breaking
bad or have a situation where maybe tuco
returns uh unless it's just a single
cameo or even if it is just a single
scene you know the time with the show's
running out and we have so many plot
lines to conclude and so many characters
to set up for the breaking bad timeline
and also kind of merging the timeline of
the two shows that it is hard to imagine
it you know i mean yeah it does feel
like we're running out of road here
yeah so i mean it just depends how much
they can you know pack into the final
few episodes here without making it too
stuffed or making it feel organic and
yeah that's just the thing there's just
so much to for them to finish already
that to add new elements to it just
might not be as realistic as we
initially hoped for at least i hoped for
yeah and i i had no idea who it might be
and the first name that i saw out there
was vincent d'onofrio i guess apparently
he added peter gould at something and
maybe he had been seen you know at the
premiere or something like that i'm not
i don't remember the details exactly
then i saw the name ron perlman who for
that same reason that you know he had
been photographed with the cast that he
had been attended the premiere and um
those are both fine i i think they would
fit an actor saying a classic of all
time i mean they're they're solid
performers they're memorable people know
who they are right but then i saw this
thread on reddit it was posted by i
cooked that blue stuff or i cooked the
blue stuff it brought up this other
quote from peter gould and you know he
says just to give you a tease that i
probably shouldn't there's something in
the season that you will know that we
watch a lot of old tv so you know the
obvious conclusion from that is this is
someone who is a famous actor from
old tv
in that thread they brought up the fact
that carol burnett had said publicly
that she loves the show and she would
like to be in it and she actually lives
in santa fe new mexico i don't even know
how much of a cultural impact she has
for
young people these days but you know
she's definitely like a titan of tv when
it comes down to it i think it would be
cool to see her in the show but it would
be kind of odd to choose considering
that jimmy did mention her by name in an
earlier season to i think rebecca i
believe so it might feel weird having
her real name mentioned in universe just
to have her then play a character unless
she's gonna play herself which i don't
know how that would work um my own
prediction that i was thinking of no way
this is probably going to happen but i
wanted a willem dafoe cameo possibly as
a detective maybe looking into howard's
disappearance i'm mainly just saying
this due to the fact that uh i just
watched american psycho for the first
time last weekend great film and to be
honest there's just way too many actors
to choose from and i'm not incredibly
cultured on the era that vince and peter
usually pull from we'll just have to
wait and see i suppose uh i mean it's
one of those things like when it show
when they show up we'll know who they
were talking about and it'll probably
make sense but i don't think we're going
to get there i mean at least you know i
spent a little bit of time looking what
people were saying because like i said i
had no idea you know to me it was just
like well that could be anybody so i
guess we could move on to this lab
teaser and um i was i know you made a
video about this and i i went looking
for that this morning and when i was
doing that i saw that that there are a
couple of channels that are putting out
the leaks for 608 so i just wanted to i
meant to say this earlier but i just
wanted to bring it up again please don't
tell me what happens in the comments of
608 if i wanted to find that information
if other people wanted to find that
information they could go look for it
um
i'd prefer to watch it as it was
intended you know and and just sort of
experience it for myself rather than
having somebody else tell me about it
but yeah i watched i watched your video
because um i knew we were doing this
today
and you know you mentioned this this
lollo mic you know whose voice was it
the debate that went on and that was
pretty much the big takeaway i had from
this in the beginning like i watched it
on my phone while i was scrolling
twitter
first couple of times whenever i you
know played it i didn't have the sound
so when i turned the sound on i was
already thinking about the lab and
already thinking about mike and gus so
it did sound like mike to me
initially and then later uh tom schnauz
came you know he confirmed that it was
lalo in the comments and so we know
that's the case
and really the only other thing that
happens is that the lights go out and
that brings us back to
gus's time you know that where he was
there hiding the gun and um it could be
a misdirect he could
actually be talking about anyone
my initial thing when i when i heard it
and i thought it was mike was i thought
maybe they were talking about howard you
know like his body's there what to do
with you
um
knowing it's lollo like i said and like
you pointed out in your video i mean it
does hint that this showdown is gonna
happen at the lab but we kind of already
knew that the the big question is how do
they get there and none of it really
makes sense because you know it depends
on what happens in that apartment
what kind of impression did this leave
on you
so it is kind of crazy how the teaser
makes it seem like we get that
confrontation between lalo and gus and
mike down in the super lab even after
the show subverted our expectations in
607 by having wallow go to jimmy and kim
instead due to his original plans being
compromised and i've discussed this a
few times
on my channel i have a whole video about
what lalo's plans are for jimmy and kim
and why he's confronting them how he's
gonna use them how jimmy and kim are
gonna get out of this situation alive
but uh going back to that 605 gun that
that gus planted i feel like it does
have to come to fruition somehow and it
is kind of weird thinking of gus using a
gun to kill as i've kind of said in my
videos he's never really used a gun on
screen he only uses his hands to kill as
an intimidation tactic and if gus wants
someone killed with a gun that's what he
has people for like mike or tyrus or any
of his other men uh i do like the idea
that people have been saying in the
comments about how
uh truly uh the whole mike versus lalo
uh situation and dynamic i feel like it
would be more suitable for
mike to actually take down lalo for gus
instead of gus doing it himself now
i i believe that mike waited upstairs
while gus planted the gun so i don't
know if he just tells him about it
off-screen or what the deal with that is
you'd think that mike would have a gun
on himself anyways uh we know that it's
just tyrus's crew at the laundromat so
falallo goes in to kill everyone we know
that he won't kill tyrus because he has
that breaking bad plot armor maybe
they'll take him as a hostage to lure
gus there but i don't really think gus
would care enough to risk himself for
tyrus i i did see a theory in my
comments however that maybe tyrus fails
to protect the super lab causing him to
get demoted while mike gets promoted for
taking care of wallow himself and i i do
again love the dynamic between lalo and
mike or michael uh i feel like lalo has
sort of grown a liking to him uh maybe
even just in an ironic way but i would
love for them to have one final
confrontation between or maybe even
multiple between each other uh possibly
elaborating on that dynamic more because
i think that those two characters could
work wonders together on screen
i think i have the opposite view on that
like i think i understand what you're
saying about gus not using a gun but i
think that also makes it kind of more
exciting if he does do that here and it
would possibly catch lalo off guard you
know what i mean like he's
we would expect it he would be expecting
you know
his guys to protect him and
that might be the way that he gets the
upper hand i don't i don't unders i
can't imagine a way that they get down
there together
unless they just catch lalo i mean
i can't see mike walking down there
armed if lalo's in control the situation
at all like it seems like the way you
said you know it that they set this up
like they made a big deal of of gus
being able to
count out the steps to where it's at
from that light
i thought that the actual plug was
just a a a reference point because
nothing's going to move in there but
people pointed out in in the comments of
my videos that maybe he
that's how he turns the lights off which
is pretty obvious but and i hadn't
really thought of it but
you know then you see him find that he
then he he walks his way over to where
he's gonna find it but even with all of
that seeming
completely sensible and obvious there
still is that idea of how does he shoot
somebody in the dark like it's not an
easy thing to do
so it's pretty fascinating how how
there's just so much of it that doesn't
really make sense but it also seems
absolutely inevitable like like you're
saying you know why have that set up
seen why have this teaser
if it doesn't all come down to something
something happening there and
that playing a part in that you know
yeah and it's it's all about how you
know if we do have this confrontation in
the super lab it's really all about how
they get there right does lalo go there
first and he lures them there or maybe
they capture lala somehow and bring him
there uh themself as sort of a spot to i
you know it all depends where they
confront lalo and how that situation
goes down i don't know you know if they
confronted him somewhere privately they
could just kill him there instead of
bringing him to the super lab but i i'm
not too sure i definitely feel like that
gun has to come to fruition i feel like
it is just a class classic chekhov's gun
and i don't think that they would have
thrown that scene in there as a red
herring and also
just to clarify with the whole uh gus
using a gun thing uh just because we
haven't seen him do it before doesn't
mean that he can't right like he
definitely still can he could just shoot
lalo and that could be that it could be
as simple as that but i just like
thinking about the idea of how gus has
never actually done that before on
screen and that he usually has other
people do it for him while
when he does kill it's for a very
different reason do you have any i mean
to me
i've been on the record as saying that i
don't i think there's absolutely zero
chance that that lalo gets out of this
alive this this phase of the story are
you holding on to any idea that maybe
this is
not going to be the end of lalo oh well
i mean just the fact that i love tony
dalton so much and i love seeing lalo on
screen i i kind of want his yeah i mean
i get that too i mean i'm in the same
boat there but i mean story-wise as far
as you know speculating on what's gonna
happen do you think it makes sense if
lalo gets out of this part of the story
alive
right yeah so so just to directly answer
that no i don't i don't think so i think
that lalo is going to die within the
next few episodes i i don't really think
that he's going to make it into the gene
timeline or any of those theories i was
just kind of saying that you know just
my
my likeness for
lalo and tony dalton is kind of
affecting how long i want him to survive
uh same with in regards to nacho i mean
i would have loved to see him in more of
the season i knew he was probably gonna
die eventually but would have been nice
to see more of nacho just because he was
my favorite character from better call
saul
but yeah no i don't think that lalo is
going to survive too much longer sadly i
think that does have to conclude somehow
and i think that gus has to know that
lalo's dead going into
breaking bad because he tells hector
that he's the last salamanca at one
point and you know ever since season
five or four better call saul there's
been the theory that maybe oh lalo goes
into hiding and then he pops out in the
gene timeline but i i just don't think
that he's able to fake his death again
and go through that whole rigmarole
again uh i i do honestly think that lalo
is probably dead by the time that we get
to gene or even breaking bad
yeah and i kind of want the the
conclusion of the series to be about
jimmy aka saul and you know possibly kim
if she's still there or i imagine that
whatever happens with them
is going to be affecting what happens in
the end
i don't really need you know lalo was a
great character he he he played his his
role he really spiced things up he was a
scene stealer and
i'm really glad that he was involved but
what happens to him isn't really
intertwined with the end of the story of
of jimmy mcgill yeah
i think there's plenty i think there's
plenty to explore in that on its own
just uh just have we talked about um
lalo like the the dialogue possibly
being lalo talking about howard's body
uh yeah i mean i just kind of brushed
over earlier like i said he could be
talking about anyone here it could be
yeah he could be talking about gus he
could be talking about mike he could be
talking about howard jimmy and kim
pretty much everyone that's still alive
and they have been kind of misleading
with teasers before and they've also not
really established a time frame with any
of the ones that they've shown after
607. do you think this one hints that
the showdown coming sooner rather than
later yeah well i was just i was just
wondering if the whole what to do with
you happens during a different moment if
this is some trailer trickery being
spliced together with just the clip of
the super lab with the lights turning
off specifically during the trailer just
spliced together to get us thinking it
would be interesting if lala was talking
about what to do with howard's body but
i i think that he'd leave jimmy and kim
to clean that mess up after you know
potentially you're probably keeping them
alive and i i wonder just to i i did
touch on this more in my my other videos
but i wonder if jimmy and kim do you say
that they've been interacting with mike
or if they kind of use nacho as a fall
guy now now the comments pointed out to
me in my video that
i don't think jimmy and kim know that
nacho is dead because he would be the
perfect fall guy for them to use uh
since he was already to blame for the
assassination attempt and yada yada so
i'm thinking that maybe lalo could just
kind of casually mention that nacho was
blamed for it and that he's dead and
then jimmy and kim could possibly use
that to their advantage uh because you
know as we've discussed uh kind of
behind the scenes and probably in
previous live streams uh
jimmy and kim do need to not only give
lalo enough information to get him off
of their back but they need to prove
themselves to be worthy of being kept
alive so as you said lalo doesn't just
kill them alongside howard even after
getting information out of them yeah i
think you're right they don't know that
that nacho died i don't think there's
any way they could find that out and he
is a likely scapegoat because yeah
there's there's some potential there um
for his name to come up i guess or
something along those lines or a
discussion about that i think we kind of
covered everything we need to on this
teaser is there anything else that
you're thinking about before we move on
i know i think that pretty much does it
one other thing is they did have the
four-year consideration stuff they're
putting bob and ray and uh jonathan
banks out for
emmytalk and um i just i hope that they
actually just give them all the emmys
already i mean i i think that the second
half of the season will be eligible the
next time because of the way that it's
broken up but uh i really hope we get to
see
some recognition on that front at the
end of this yeah i i agree i agree
completely uh long story short i think
it's criminal uh how much they get
snubbed uh at the enemies especially
during season five and i really hope
that all of these amazing actors get the
recognition that they deserve for season
six along with the all of the creators
the writers the directors all of that
yeah i mean it's just it's just so
top-notch and you know there's a lot of
other stuff that goes into it so like i
don't want to go down a rabbit hole and
you know talk out of school about it but
i did want to bring that up give them
the emmys already and i think we can um
you know wrap things up here thanks for
coming and talking about this stuff i
thought it would be a decent
conversation i think we had that i just
wanted to say thanks for having me on
for the video it was uh really fun
discussing all this i do love kind of
just theorizing about the show in
general on twitter whether to other
creators or just uh you know viewers of
the show in general so it was really
nice to come on here sort of halfway
through the mid-season break and just
discuss where we're at discuss what
we're thinking and how we think that the
rest of the season is going to go down
so again thank you so much for having me
on i appreciate it and yeah this was a
lot of fun yeah and so if you're
watching just let us know in the
comments what you think about all this
new stuff
what you think about this format in
general i've thought about doing some
other ones with different people that
have come on over over time when we do
the live stream so let me know what you
think about that and definitely give the
the vivid kiwi channel a look i'll put
the links in the description please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon